you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game let's see
you
let's see what chesa holic says they
were wondering if I was recording I
guess you'll be seeing this eventually
alrighty
I sure to b5 it's Castle and I like this
line opening up
the f1 square I'll be going for C 3 and
d 4 I like H 3 like holding off on
playing D form for a little bit
I want to see black commits first now
we're gonna push and then play D form
and where to go what my bishop wants
challenged okay feels early to do that
giving me the c3 square but maybe I mean
that's quite alright Bishop their Knight
g5 is my first thought is that really
best don't know let's see if I could
induce some weakening moves h6 let's get
my rook on c1 h6 Bishop back
hmm I can also look for now that they
didn't play h6 I could go for Queen to
d2 let's do this this is a sensitive
square for sure I am prepared to take
him out let's come all the way back I
may be able to just do this move b3 and
work against this Knight maybe maybe I
should have factored that in I think I
think this is still fine I'm running it
I could I couldn't look to attack the
King all right what's what's being lined
up here this kind of stuff
and g4 is pretty aggressive can I do
without that yeah let's try it
well let's see what the bishop does
first they're gonna back up this is my
bad Bishop to be careful of this my
Knight goes too far this is a pretty
annoying move there could be if I'm ever
capturing and this could be an issue
you know just jumping right in well as
its points I'm going to take them out
and I think take here
hmm you know let's take there and now
what this move followed up with Queen
here hmm
soon this bishops gonna be anchored into
d3 it scares me
well let's let's try this this Knights
ready to drop in there and noted can i
stir up some trouble I'm going to have
to soon
rook - eats free
yeah I don't see no I don't think I have
a some kind of an attack here
Queen to d4 and then just giving up the
exchange hmm let's
ah now that's let's go into two extreme
I have to come up with something here
this night on d3 is a beast he's soon to
be a beast could go g4 for starters
Bishop d3 though hmm well let's do this
yeah if the bishops on d3 at least I
don't have to worry about the knight on
d3 and if the bishop goes here then
Queen d4 is threatening this with
discovered check and I could get the
bishop so let's see what the decision is
with this guy probably still here how am
i defending this
okay I guess he's just gonna go down and
I have nothing is that what we're
staring at that kind of a position you
have to play b3 here hmm let's try to
stir up some trouble with e6 so much for
that all right let's continue try to
break down their King position some
let's take you know and I maybe am right
around the corner are going to be losing
this guy not a good game look at my king
position on top of all of this oh boy
okay played maybe a bit too fast I'd
like to see Knight takes Knight but it's
never gonna happen my rook on c1 looks
silly
my queen can't get playing ooh that's a
bit of a surprising move I'm probably
still worse but how are they tracking
this pawn down my knight has some
security let's make some active move now
look two double keep pressure on the
bishop definitely can't lose that pawn
good look for these kind oh they could
force the Queen's off but still the
ending is yeah they're going for that
and maybe this move or now let's go here
first
I'm heading at g5 and then maybe a four
I have to be concerned about my knight
being undermined let's defend my rook
first b5 is a strong move hmm not
calling with b5 okay this looks a little
bit odd but let's go I could grab that
pawn right away I only have 53 seconds I
could take that pawn but I have this
move
if to double the rooks I get the rook on
d6 I want the beep on I could win this
guy to the upper okay maybe they
struggle a bit more to get this pawn I
shouldn't have eaten up the H pawn now
they have a past H phone ok let's get
here
a4 a5 I'm down a bunch of stuff hmm
let's try a four you know all right
let's see if I could try to hold on here
the King could also enter
yikes I think I'm gonna have to give up
my night for the bishop if it takes here
and get that beep on yeah this is just
good start marching those pawns some
okay and g4 let's play here first h4 is
good let's just lock down 26 seconds
mm-hmm it's a little bit of an odd move
I'd say let's try to be a pest with my
King somehow somehow I got this square
covered I think could just start pushing
that pond got to come back have some
activity
like to take the bishop and then take
the h-bond
can't take with the kanga
yeah this is dead last
let's take their you have to try to get
that pond yeah 11 seconds as well
yeah they're allowing me to get a queen
but they are fast enough they could
still get pushing and there's a fork
there that's a good time to resign
poorly played game my opponent took
advantage of my mistakes well
let's go through it analysis yeah I
really let them have my way have their
way into my position here with these
light squares so let's see let me play
it a little bit too fast
I'm fine with this position but right
around here even maybe before Queen to
d2 this is important because why not
play b3 just squash this is a very poor
piece this is his only square let's kill
that take this Knight out of the
equation right away and then and then
move forward with this stuff so b3 Queen
to d2 oh I never even knew that this
name was connected with this opening his
mid nob Rhossili mo yeah probably b3
play against this Knight not give up my
light square bishop because this is this
is awkward I mean the bishop on e3 I
would be hesitant to play a move like b3
if the bishop could come out here but
there isn't a good way to take advantage
of the the gap that's left behind with
b3 so this is this is a far more
positive than a negative
I like the b3 move I'm too quick with
Queen to d2 I believe now I know they
don't go straight in for a knight c4
even here even here I have another
opportunity for b3 and I should be going
for that however right around this point
my concern is the knight slipping into
these squares no but that shouldn't be
concerned I have this covered the rook
and the bishop I should be going with b3
here I could do it over I'd be going
with v3 here this is - this is too quick
and I'm not maybe right around here it's
still equal but I have to be accurate
for sure and there's no three versus two
there's a pawn to my position there's an
outpost on d3 I have
some serious light-square weaknesses and
I was lucky to even get into an endgame
that I was even I was lucky to even get
to a point here where I had a strong
night on this square but I'm down upon
I'll still a ton of things bad but uh
yeah I definitely deserve to lose this
one
played it not good not good
my opponent pounced on my mistakes well
be three instead of Bishop here I could
do this whenever one slave III and then
go from there he's out of play and I
don't have to worry about my opponent
entering here now I have time for this
I could try to uh try to attack
yeah the b3 move why did I play b3 Oh No
from here got pounced on it's uh you
know just kind of lashing out right
around this point
Queen d4 could just jump in that's just
a check
and in the end I'm still losing the
exchange yeah I just I don't like my
decision to play Bishop h6 as soon as I
did kill this knight first keep him a
bad piece and then go with this idea I
think would be better let's see what the
graph is saying let's look at the point
right here whoa
it does like me even with this variation
I won't have expected that I had to
follow up better right here then I think
this was the point where I was saying I
got it I gotta come up with something
well you just saw I did not come up with
something I went with the g4 and it
wants to go with rook e to d1 and it
still says that it's even ish
oh it's before that
oh when I played d5 okay that's that's a
little bit weird it says d5
holding it at a point seven and then
after night to be for after it sees the
move Knight to be for its saying that it
prefers black
oh yeah what to make of that
exchange d5 that okay not quite sure why
it's uh saying that okay odd yeah it's
it's no good to even try to work around
this night the the improvements are much
further back
you know if I was playing as black I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have captured
here
Queen d6 it likes better yeah I felt
black did give some a little something
up when they did that but even so my
night could be undermined with this kind
of stuff they have a very nice central
Queen they could get the Queen's off
like they did in the game and he could
even be hunted down like it happened in
the game but yeah I'm able to have this
night for at least a little bit and as a
result this pawn but they undermined
everything well from here on out
yeah goes from bad to worse
didn't have to drop my H pon I could do
this but he's going to get hunted down
I'm gonna be losing another pawn got
nothing so let me just look at the b3
move that's really the last point
instead of Bishop to h6 it wants to go
with Bishop h6 now I'm gonna look at b3
well let's try Bishop h6 first and I
here does want to take and then take and
then Knight to e4 even doing this is
scary I gotta do awkward stuff it's not
fun night here to stop knight to b4 no
I'm gonna do without Bishop h6 I like b3
doesn't have an issue with b3 it's a
nice controlling move don't have to
enter any type of imbalance don't have
to invest the bishop for night and play
from here look at this next move you
have six it suggests Bishop h6 yeah a
much more controlled position
I like this far better if you do a
knight comparison I'm referring my
Knights over blacks this is a poor piece
so I should try to keep it there keep it
as poor b3 be looking for that next time
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye